i don't think it's gonna come as a shock
to anyone
but garrett and i have decided to end
our engagement
becca kufrin is back to being a
bachelorette the reality star revealed
that she and fiance garrett yergoian
have called it quits after two years
during tuesday's episode of her bachelor
happy hour podcast
if you have followed us on instagram for
the past couple months
you'll have noticed that i spent a lot
of time in minnesota i was with family
and close friends
and he was out on the west coast doing
the same and we were really just trying
to take time
and gain some clarity on
as to what was the next best step in our
lives whether that was together
or as individuals becca went on to
explain that this wasn't a decision she
and garrett
came to overnight there's much more to
it
that you know there's to any
relationship there's a lot of layers and
it's not for me to divulge details
but you know
for anyone out there who's gone through
a breakup you know that
it's never easy it's a roller coaster of
emotions
and you have these ups and these downs
and you just
try to take it day by day the former
bachelorette
says that at the end of the day their
paths just went different ways
we went on this crazy tv show
over two years ago in hopes of finding
love
and we were lucky enough that we did
um we really truly did
and um i'm so grateful
for that opportunity since night one i
saw something in you i felt something in
you
so much so that you got that first rose
you got that first impression rose
because
you know right away i felt something so
strong
garrett proposed to becca at the end of
her 2018
season of the abc reality show during a
romantic trip to the maldives
we're building our dream home out of
sand
talking about our kids talking about a
future
i knew that i loved you so much and i
wanted to spend the rest of my life with
you
on tuesday becca recalled the future she
thought they would have together
we also thought that we had a future
that would be set in stone
we thought that we'd buy a house
together and have a dog
and you know probably add children to
the mix one day and
again life happens and people sometimes
drift apart and have
differences and and they go their
separate ways she ended her speech by
requesting
privacy as she and yargoyan determine
what's best for us
and how to navigate this difficult time
i just hope
that from here on out
the rumors can be put to bed and that
garrett and i can
now move on into the next chapter of our
lives that's hopefully
fingers crossed the best the best ones
yet
kufrin also shared news of the couple's
split on instagram
writing in part quote with a heavy heart
garrett and i have come to the loving
conclusion
to end our engagement as a woman i feel
like sometimes we're much more intuitive
yes becca know what's in her head and in
our hearts and know how those can align
the best
but it's no secret that trouble's been
brewing for some time
neither kufrin nor urgoine have posted
photos of each other on social media
since may not to mention their
relationship has been under scrutiny
from the start
i love you so much not just now
but forever you're my world you're going
in first ignited controversy
while becca's season of the bachelorette
was airing
after fans discovered that he'd liked
racist and sexist posts on social media
the 31 year old apologized calling his
double taps
mindless and while kufrin didn't condone
his behavior
she did stick by him i trust my gut i
know what's right for me
and so i know at the end of the day i
will make that right choice
in june the california native made
headlines again
this time sharing a pro-police post on
instagram
amid the black lives matter movement
when i read his post
i think what was so troubling for me in
addition to just the thin
the thin blue line is that i don't
understand when he says i've listened
learned
helped supported and i've grown
and then everything thereafter
contradicts that entire line
fellow bachelorette rachel lindsay
confronted kufrin about the post
on their podcast what is it that he has
learned and how is it that he's grown
because we don't see it with this
statement
as for kufrin's response once again she
didn't excuse your goyin's behavior but
she did
say this i think his heart is in the
right place
i think it's bad timing and it does come
across as tone deaf the next week kufrin
told listeners
that she was uncertain of the couple's
future for those who are curious about
my relationship with garrett at this
point um
all i can say right now is that i i
don't know
i can't give anything more than that
it's something that we are
trying to work through and discuss and
do work on at home at this time
um and that's where the work will remain
and that's
really the best i can give you at this
point but i wanted to
share this um i know i've been rambling
for a bit but to
give a little bit more context and to
give you rachel my apology
and to really throw my voice and hat in
the ring
to say uh things need to change within
the franchise and within
myself as well your goyan has yet to
post about
or comment on the couple's split